hey what's up guys we are
and i'm kihan i'm joe honey i'm young i
am i am mini and we're gonna play who's
who buddy let's go wow
[Music]
hi
hi
why
i mean i think he forgets a lot a lot he
just stands in the middle of the stage
like
he just stopped yes i don't know the
reason most forget people with young man
but
uh creative we have
creative people what do you mean
hi whoa famous everything is best oh
there's fast and he forgets
everything everywhere everything
everywhere doesn't matter where it is
yeah exercise is kind of like a daily
routine for me so yeah you wake up i go
to the gym with him
workout that's it yeah you need some
fresh thing
hi
oh my god
fast and slow
not interested right yes faster
he's the main character of buzzfeed yeah
he's made wow
hello
[Music]
before
yeah that's all right
i didn't know
every day yeah
you're always angry
in games
hey shut up okay sorry lol league of
legends yeah
what do you think about that
why are you taking a lot of selfies um
okay
gta yeah gta but new series neville
never come
so i party
you left the game yeah i left the game
mm-hmm he played lgbt i played p.e.s i
had building and club in gta he's owner
he's an owner super car
not building adelaide yeah don't you he
loved that
no no no
no no just one by one
just delivery food delivery he likes
cooking but
these days i don't know sometimes it
cooks but well too busy really sometimes
really sometimes yeah
yeah maybe him maybe me
i'm a house lover
right
now
okay on aka homeless
tick tocker in monster
let's go i want to
i want to tick tocker but that is too
hard yeah yeah oh camera
movie
yeah angle of the camera is too hard
what's the thing that you learned lately
lately
i was you i wanna be me too let's go
like a rivo boom
okay
um
he already wrote two title songs before
yeah yeah the korean album you're really
willing but i am and come on
also there are some writers so
you're looking for it oh no no i'm not
interested about writing a title song
really like
why i don't want to like feel kind of
pressured
thank you so much for having us and
actually we dropped our new album the
dreaming um
and we prepared ten songs it's a regular
album i hope you guys enjoy and listen a
lot thank you thank you thank you please
you